هناك نحو اربعه
الاف ربما من
المناطق الحدوديه قرب بالجورود حيث تدور
المعارك
نعم صحيح عثمان هذا ما اكده اليوم حاكم
مقاطعه
الذي اكد على ان اربعه الاف نازح من مناطق
شبيكنا
وغيرها من البلدات المتاخمه لحدود مقاطعه
خارقيبه الاوكرانيه والتي تتعرض للقصف منذ
اكثر من اسبوع
وصلوا الى مراكز الايواء وهنا حيث نحن
الان اكبر مركز لواء النازحين وسط مدينه
هذه النقطه يتم فيها تسجيل الواصلين من
تلك المناطق وبعد ذلك يقيمون لليله او
ليلتين فقط في هذا المركب الرياضي من تم
يتم نقلهم الى مراكز ايواء اخرى وهي عباره
لنقل هي بمعايير اخرى اكثر ملائمه لواء
هؤلاء النازحين الى حين انتهاء حلقه هذا
القصف الذي تتحدث عنه السلطات الروسيه
للمناطق
الحدوديه طبعا كلاتكوف اكد ان هذه العمليه
هي عمليه الاجلاء ما زالت متواصله باتجاه
مدينه وهناك ايضا عمليه النزوح اخرى يتم
من خلالها ارسال المدنيين وخاصه الاطفال
الى مقاطعات روسيه اخرى اكثر امنا وكنا
امس قد رصدنا ذلك بالتوجه اكثر من 600 طفل
الى مقاطعتي
كلوغاستافل القريبتين من مقاطعه موسكو الى
حين هدوء الاوضاع لنقل في هذه المنطقه
ايضا اكد على ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
اعترضت اهدافا جويه فوق مدينه بيلجرود امس
مساء سمعنا عمل هذه الدفاعات الجويه كانت
هناك انفجارات فوق مدينه
واكد ايضا على ان بلده مورون القريبه من
شبيكنا الواقعه تحديد على المعبر الحدودي
لشبكنا مع مقاطعه خار كيف تعرضت لقصف ادى
الى تضرر مدرسه وروضه للاطفال ومصحه
وبعض الممتلكات الشخصيه للسكان واكد على
ان حصيله قتل امس من المدنيين في تلك
المنطقه بلغ مقتل مدنيين اثنين وجرح اثني
عشر اخرين واكد على ان السلطات الروسيه ما
زالت تواصل جهودها اولا من اجل الحيلوله
دون تضرر المدنيين ثم خلق ظروف ملائمه
لاواء النازحين من تلك المناطق عثمان شكرا
جزيلا لكم من درغامي من مدينه بلغرود
وايضا عدنان بوريني من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف